[Music]
hey it's Jessie I'm here in Antarctica
I'm actually at the tech conference just
really cold here I'm here just talking
with developers very interesting people
using our technology in pretty cool ways
and I'm here with shadi could you tell
me a little bit about what you're doing
here at the tech conference specifically
and also what you do here at Wolfram
research I'm the manager of image and
audio processing or at least that
selfish shell title we do a lot of image
audio processing we're looking into
video for the future and also we're
doing we're taking over some of the
import/export capabilities and the
Wolfram research at the tech conference
as for our team which is unique and all
remote we it's always a family reunion
for us as a team to come here and you
know see each other in person and more
important than that we see a lot of
users that are interacting and utilizing
our software and our capabilities in
their day to day applications cool and
get feedback which is very oh yeah
that's probably the best thing about
this so I for those who weren't here I
talked to shadi last year about you know
what's new and image and audio
processing so can you tell me a little
bit about what's new since I last spoke
with you a year ago a lot of neural
network integration obviously a lot of
high-level functions that are already
ready to get released in 12 and a lot
more pipe in the pipeline for us after
12 obviously it's a very hot topic
everybody talks about machine learning
neural nets and there is a reason behind
it the the a lot of attempts for giving
so many applications to work accurately
are now getting to a point that you can
real accuracy out of them so that for
surveillance systems or for automobile
industry or for any other reasons you
can actually rely on computer it's doing
things accurate before you and not fail
30 percent of the time which is a very
bad thing in the on the screen I have an
example of face detection we have had
this I think since version eight or nine
we were proud to say that in 12 the
quality of this is gonna be a lot better
than what it was before so it is getting
into the industry level of quality and
in 12 and we keep obviously improving it
if we can or if you see if you see
problems or failures we're constantly
going to improve on that but also just
not doing improvements on face detection
for instance in this particular case
we're always looking into ways of adding
arguments to the functions and making it
more usable useful things like in this
picture I can find all the faces but I
can also ask for all the faces that
approximate it to be 30 years old or
older and this is gives this giving back
the mom and dad or for instance we are
doing landmark facial landmark analysis
as another neural network that was out
there we converted it and we're using it
and we're not stopping at there we are
looking into having things like face
morphing or phasing facial effects make
me feather or feather or morph me to
this or that person add make up because
we know where is the location of
different pieces of a face or so many
other things oh yeah I feel like in like
snapchat and like Instagram they have
all these like makeup filters or you
know just fun filters and we love
calling fun but we sometimes like to get
serious you know like for a lot of
surgeries for instance plastic surgeries
or
you know after access and things like
that people do need to simulate what's
gonna happen after so you know it all
the fun is always fun but serious stuff
are also happening in the world so so
this is gonna have a whole lot of
applications out there we have the
neural network repository obviously
released this year thanks to our
wonderful neural network team and
machine learning team I was looking at
the networks that are out there 56 of I
think about the hundreds or more than
half or image related networks and this
as well is gonna open up a whole lot of
applications that can be implemented
this is a simple fun example that
translates that's what it's called in
the literature a horse to a zebra or you
know there are other models that can do
hand drawing for the real estate or a
real photograph or do the other way
around and things like that that that's
about it for image well not that but
that's the one of the most important
thing that's happening with image and
audio um so you mentioned import export
can you tell me a little bit about some
of the new responsibilities that picked
up from import the export has come to us
because just the images on their own
have in in mathematical we have about 25
formats for images that we can we could
have always imported and exported and
then we started making some of those
optimized and then we grew expertise in
knowing how our import export framework
works and how we can add more keep more
you know hook up to new formats that we
don't that we didn't support or make
them more more efficient and through
that process we realized a whole lot of
inconsistencies unfortunately in our
system or inefficiencies and then I
guess we are
taking good-size steps I wouldn't call
them baby steps towards having
consistent important export partial
access which is also very important for
very large images but as well for very
large datasets very large excel files
very large CSV so it kind of comes all
over the place that we would like to
have efficient access to parts of a file
rather than the whole file which was the
main focus of Mathematica is important
export I think up to last one or two
versions and things like that so
although a lot of other teams are also
working and are responsible for their
specific formats that is within their
expertise domain we're kind of having a
bigger look at our import export
capabilities making sure we are all
doing your designs for the export
consistently and we are doing it
efficiently that's basically the big
story around that cool um so what else
do you have in this in this new I put a
few other examples we well these are
blue but they are actually going to be
released in 12 we also have some neural
networks trained for audio and we have
very good and strong all your net
encoders which can be the input to any
network and some of them like audio
spectrogram which is a free time
frequency matrix basically from an audio
object becomes a 2d object then at that
point you can practically
look at any image neural network and
then feed that the spectrogram and it
was gonna do the tasks whether its
classification identification or some
transforms Reiss tiles and things like
that on the audio signal so we have a
good collection of audio net encoders
which just makes audio ready to be
digested by a neural network and then
obviously people are working on a whole
lot of different kinds of structures to
do different kinds of tasks a few
examples this one is a pitch recognizer
of a
play of a piano that we have in our
example data and we recognize a pitch of
those notes then we have audio identify
is another one like our image identify
this is a bird singing and then you get
five top identifications with their
probabilities coming back speech
recognition has a lot of uses everywhere
so that's another thing that is coming
built into Mathematica for now only for
English we are going to be looking into
other languages for proposed 12 and then
updated speech synthesized with new
languages is also coming in the world of
audio with a whole lot of other more
minor updates obviously it's going to be
released in the notes but I'm not going
to mention everything right right
there's like a demo over the audience
can see but there's a demo I think that
uses some of this audio identification
functionality to kind of compare your
voice to like what animal thinks you are
what are some more like maybe serious
applications of that sort of
functionality for audio identification
right that so all you identify on its
own this is an experimental function
that is getting released in 12 on its
own it has you know it's it's useful
application you can say this audio
recording has human speaking in it as
well as some within the background and
things like that so you may just use it
on its own as a kind of a scene analysis
audio scene analysis or tagging
semantically tagging your audio with
different components that it has but
also what is very very important with
audio identify that is coming is that
it's giving us a very good feature
extractor for audio so in a lot of times
we see that then trained neural network
is chopped and say the you know one of
the lungs
lastly years of the network and then you
reattach another a few layers to that
network or use that layer you know two
or three before the end which does that
say
identification tasks and then use that
as your audio feature and then classify
that or as I said attach another few
layers to it do another training with a
smaller much smaller typically data set
and do completely different thing like a
song identification or mood
classification on a person speaking in
the cases that you are seeing back there
we have a network trained on some
celebrity voice data that we have found
and then we can even find who you sound
like
last year we had a demo I think it's
still running in the booth as well who
do you look like among celebrities we
have what do you sound like this year so
yeah these are just some again fun
examples but but imagine in serious word
you would like to separate a long
recording between person one and two
speaking and then do analysis on them
per speaker rather than throw the whole
thing I see okay it kind of exhausted
all this was happening a lot this year
everyone's just kind of on the ball this
year do you have anything else you want
to talk oh I added this Web Audio search
in my notebook because I thought it's
cool to show that we are trying to get
access to the content that is out there
in the world more easily
obviously import/export that I talked
about already gives us a very good
strong access to the files that are
already on your part of system but like
web image search and web search we're
adding that audio search currently were
just connecting to free sound there are
other audio services not as many as they
are for images but this is going to be a
very good resource and then I added the
phone section of both color going back
to the images stuff we always had color
directives we never had a definition for
any
of colors so almost Red's almost greens
and things like that so this this is
coming and it's enabling things like I
want to recover this shoe oh yeah yeah
and then what would it look like if I
changed the almost reds to greens or
also almost pinks to blue and I think
this is already you can imagine where
this is you know go through this website
for shopping and right it keeps changing
the color but the model is seeing
exactly the same so you know that
techniques like that or are applied to
the image so very applicable in I think
merchandise industry and follow other
places I suppose yeah well thanks for
talking with me that's all the talks we
have today but tune in tomorrow and I'll
be talking with other developers
[Music]